la marina siempre ha sido bastión del
chavismo como lo decías ha estado
gobernada durante los últimos 22 años
por el chavismo por el padre de hugo
chávez por dos de sus hermanos y en esta
oportunidad no se pueden permitir
perderla se ha convertido como un punto
de honor luego de la derrota del pasado
21 de noviembre cuando frei superlano
renunció electo sin embargo el propio
tribunal supremo de justicia lo
inhabilita y manda a suspender esta
elección por considerar que estaba
inhabilitado aún cuando había sido
indultado por el propio nicolás maduro
para poder participar en estas
elecciones jorge arreaza luego de
inscribir su candidatura ante el consejo
nacional electoral habló de que iba a
retomar las promesas que en barinas no
se habían cumplido en materia de
vialidad que iba a llevar la gasolina
que incluso al ministro de vivienda iría
este martes a barinas para atender las
peticiones habló de rectificación y de
que barinas necesita un candidato que
profundice en la revolución y recordemos
que él es ex yerno del fallecido
presidente hugo chávez
daniela y auroras silva de esposa de
freddy superlano fue inhabilitada
entretanto para presentar igual que su
esposo cuando competía contra argenis
chávez cómo se recibe esa decisión en la
oposición hay algún otro candidato en
miras a postularse
no solo fue inhabilitada la esposa de su
perla no también julio si esas reyes que
era la otra opción que tenía la
oposición para postular el día de hoy
freddy su perla no anunciaba que sergio
garrido un diputado electo al consejo
legislativo de barinas el pasado 21 de
noviembre va a ser el candidato por la
oposición puesto que solo fue electo fue
ratificado pero aseguraba que igual en
barinas hay una amenaza latente para
todo aquel que pueda superar al
contendor del chavismo y pueda ganar la
gobernación incluso recordaba que
barinas ha estado militarizada desde el
pasado 22 de noviembre y lo ha
calificado como un golpe continuado
llamó al consejo nacional electoral a
cumplir su rol de árbitro